bei uns im Studio Bilde Meinung Schäfer
Philipp piathoff schönen guten Tag
Philipp hallo eine Armee die ihre
Überlegenheit was die Zahlen angeht und
was das Kriegsgerät angeht offenbar
nicht ausnutzen kann jetzt also 300.000
neue Soldaten ja das wird auf jeden Fall
etwas ausmachen es ist natürlich
fraglich wie sehr das die Kampfkraft
erhöht aber ich glaube man darf das auch
nicht komplett unterschätzen auch wenn
diese 300.000 natürlich nicht alle an
die Front kommen wenn viele von ihnen
nicht ausreichend ausgebildet werden
dennoch ist das so wenn man so eine
gewaltige Anzahl von Menschen irgendwo
hinschickt dann wird das ein Unterschied
machen und vieles deutet darauf hin dass
das auch nicht bei 300.000 bleibt
sondern dass da womöglich noch zwei
weitere mobil machenswellen kommen und
insgesamt bis zu einer Million russische
Männer dann in die Ukraine verlegt
werden und das werden die Ukrainer auch
spüren und davon gehen sie auch aus das
sagen sie auch ganz offen es wird auf
jeden Fall Einfluss auf den Krieg nehmen
jetzt berichten wir schon die ganze Zeit
über Proteste Russland über Schießereien
gerade eben noch im Bericht in
rekrutierungs
Rekrutierung eine Güte
Rekrutierungsbüros wie sehr ist die
Stimmung da jetzt schon gekippt ich
würde nicht sagen dass die Stimmung
tatsächlich schon gekippt ist wir
richten uns wir richten unsere
Aufmerksamkeit natürlich immer auf diese
Zwischenfälle auf die Demonstranten auf
das Brände Rekrutierungsbüro auf den
Anschlag auf einen Offizier aber die
Masse der Russen macht mit das muss man
sich einfach weiterhin vor Augen führen
die Kameras sind natürlich immer darauf
gerichtet wenn jemand protestiert und in
den Polizeiwagen geschmissen und
verhaftet wird die Kameras richten sich
nicht auf die Masse der Menschen die das
alles befolgen und
100.000 Russen melden sich nun mal
gerade an die zum Teil freiwillig zum
Teil natürlich durch den
Einberufungsbescheid melden sich gerade
bei der Armee und werden in die Ukraine
fahren das heißt ob die Stimmung kippt
ob das bei Strohhalm bleibt das wissen
wir noch nicht ich bin bei Russland
nicht mehr so hoffnungsvoll weil man in
den vergangenen Jahren immer wieder
Hoffnung hatte Hoffnung auf Demos
Hoffnung auf Widerstand und bislang
wurden die Hoffnung immer wieder
zerschlagen einige Russen möchten sich
jetzt auch per Flucht dieser
Mobilisierung entziehen und die
Diskussion kommt auf ob wir die
geflüchteten Russen hier in Deutschland
aufnehmen sollen was hältst du von der
Idee ja also es gibt EU-Richtlinien dazu
es gibt Gesetze dazu das heißt
juristischen Markt das vielleicht völlig
klar sein wenn jemand bedroht ist von
dieser Mobilmachung und in ein
völkerrechtswidrigen verbrecherischen
Krieg eingezogen wird dann gilt er als
verfolgt und dann steht immer Sylt zu
vielleicht ist das die juristische
Perspektive was ich aber in der Politik
gerade be ist so eine Art romantische
Verklärung dieser russischen
mobilmachungsflüchtlinge da wird dann
plötzlich von Freiheitskämpfern und
kremlkritikern gesprochen und
demokratie-fans ich glaube da muss man
sich nichts in die Tasche lügen denn
diese Männer die jetzt ausreisen es
sollen offenbar über 260.000 sein die
allein in den vergangenen Tagen das Land
verlassen haben viele von ihnen haben
dieses Kreml System und auch den Krieg
unterstützt oder zumindest überhaupt
nichts dagegen getan und viele von ihnen
werden auch weiter in Russland geblieben
hätten gearbeitet Steuern gezahlt und
damit auch den Krieg mitfinanziert
solange der Krieg nur weit weg war das
heißt aus diesen Menschen dann
Freiheitskämpfer zu tun nur weil sie
nicht selbst in diesem Krieg kämpfen und
sterben wollen so weit würde ich auf gar
keinen Fall gehen jetzt heißt es in den
letzten Tagen immer wieder Putin würde
unter Druck stehen mit dem Rücken zur
Wand agieren ist dem tatsächlich so oder
ist das einfach nur Wunschdenken des
Wissens es ist glaube ich Wunschdenken
dass er darüber stolpern kann auch wenn
das natürlich immer möglich ist aber
putin ist schon seit über 20 Jahren da
macht und es deutet gerade nicht so
darauf hin dass er kurz davor steht
abgelöst zu werden aber steht auf jeden
Fall unter Druck also die mobilenmachung
die Atom Drohungen die Referenten das
sind panikhandlung denn bislang wurde
den Russen ja auch sieben Monate lang
erzählt es läuft alles nach Plan er
hatte den Russen selbst höchstpersönlich
versprochen es wird keine mobil machen
geben das heißt das jetzt dass er jetzt
dieses Risiko eingeht auch
innenpolitisch 100.000 Männer einberuft
bald wahrscheinlich die Grenzen schließt
sowas macht er natürlich nicht weil es
nach Plan läuft sondern weil der Plan
komplett gescheitert ist und das wissen
natürlich alle um ihn herum das wissen
auch diese sogenannten Hardliner die
noch radikaler sind als er und die ihn
natürlich versuchen damit unter Druck zu
setzen das heißt ja putin ist steht auf
jeden Fall unter massivem Druck weil
alles was er nur keine geplante bislang
komplett zerschlagen wurde vor allem
dank des heldenhaften Widerstands der
Ukraine sagt bildmeinungschef Philipp
piatov herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch
danke euch
[Musik]